[Music]
what's up y'all sean here sam is in
europe traveling around with the fam and
uh so i'm on my own today and i wanted
to do something cool and i think i got a
great idea so i believe here's my guess
i think this pod is going to be one that
people really really like because i know
i would have
wanted to hear this at some point in
time and the reason why is because most
of the people who listen to this podcast
are
some form of leadership right you might
have started your own company or your
own business
uh you might be kind of an exact
somewhere or a manager somewhere or you
want to be a leader right so
most people who
don't want to be leaders are not
listening to a podcast like this
so
the problem is
me and everybody else sucks you know
everybody sucks the first time that they
are managing people
and um
and this isn't like you know how to
manage people 101 there's a lot of books
that are written about this
there's some best practices there's
common sense
but i wanted to share some of the
unorthodox some of the weird things that
i do that i have found work for me and
they might not work for everybody but
they work for me
and
not all of these people are going to
agree with
not all of these will work for you but
again they all work for me nobody i
couldn't find any of this stuff in a
book
i heard about these either from somebody
or i just kind of made it up on my own
and so i think i have five maybe six
different things that i do that are
unorthodox but work okay so let me start
with number one and this is called dr
house or it's inspired by dr house so if
anybody watches the tv show house he
always does this thing
the show is like there's this genius
doctor
uh but he's kind of like a curmudgeon
and um
all the other doctors really respect him
because he's amazing but
uh he's kind of hard to work with one of
the things he does that's amazing but
hard to work with is
he has these like three junior doctors
who are kind of like he's
i don't know advising them or whatever
they work under him
and when a patient comes in and they run
a test to try to figure out what's wrong
with the person he doesn't just look at
it and say here's what's wrong with the
person right first of all it's usually
not that straightforward second of all
even if he kind of has an idea he
doesn't spoon feed it
to his um
to his team instead he will usually slap
the the res the the like maybe the scan
or the data or the the x-ray or whatever
up on a screen and he'll say what do you
see here or he'll say what's weird about
this or he'll say what's interesting
about this and
then the team has to start thinking and
getting curious and looking at the thing
and saying well there must be something
there what do i see
and this is really effective i do this
all the time i will take
let's say some data i'm looking at when
i'm curious about something i see
something that makes me go hmm
and
what i used to do is i used to just like
share that with the team hey guys here's
what i found look at this data this data
shows that a is b and c right i would
like give them a conclusion i'm
basically
spoon feeding them an answer they'd read
it they'd say yeah that makes sense and
then they would go on with their day
right because they didn't have to
struggle to understand it they didn't
have to be curious enough to go find it
they just got spoon-fed an answer and
they say yeah yeah i'm not surprised by
that all right i'm gonna move on or oh
that's weird okay sounds like you got to
answer i'm gonna again move on
so i do it the other way which does
three things
one it trains the team to be curious and
clever right because you're not looking
for some luck i'm not telling you to go
do ten more analyses i'm saying there's
something in this what is it it's a
little bit of a riddle
the second is it's not a gotcha right
like i'm genuinely asking
because they will see things that you
don't see so even if you saw one
interesting thing they might find two
others that you didn't really
appreciate
and the last is it trains everybody on
how to
because you know maybe one person out of
the group will see the interesting thing
but the other four will say why didn't i
see that and that trial and error that
like guess and check is how people get
better at stuff so you'll train a team
of curious clever people who get good at
finding insights in data
and so
that's the dr house technique i
recommend you try it rather than spoon
feeding your team answers
okay the second one i learned from my
wife my wife was a consultant
and she used to go to these companies
and i was like it was always like i'm
getting alignment right she would go it
would be a board meeting of like you
know yahoo's board meeting it's like you
have 10 executives at yahoo and they
cannot you know they all think they're
on the same page and then only when you
ask them certain questions
do you realize that like everybody has
like a different you know game plan
vision of what we're trying to do here
et cetera et cetera
so she got good at sussing that out but
people are a little bit um
not defensive but they're a little bit
limited when you just ask them very
literal logical questions that tap into
only the analytical part of their brain
like if you say what are our three key
objectives for the year they sort of
feels like they're taking a math test
and so she does this thing that was
called the holiday party the holiday
party tactic is she had me go she had to
go to a whiteboard and she goes all
right
let's fast forward it's christmas eve
um of this year
and we're at the company holiday party i
want you to start drawing what's at the
company holiday party i'm like what do
you mean she's like just draw things
that would make it an awesome company
holiday party so i'm like okay so all of
a sudden i'm having kind of fun i'm
something creative i'm drawing i'm just
thinking of cool [__] that could be at a
party right so my guard is down and so
you know i'll draw like whatever there's
a dj and i we kind of laugh because the
dj booth is like you know my drawing is
bad
and then i'll draw the next thing and
then she'll say okay what's on the
screen what are you celebrating
and that question what are we
celebrating is like that's kind of like
what are we trying to do this year right
what's the milestone that we hit and
instead of saying what are we trying to
do it's assuming it's already done that
we're already celebrating we're popping
bottles because we hit 1 million users
or
10 million downloads or 100 million in
revenue whatever it is
and so it's you know we'd say our big
north star goal because it's like that
screen can only have one big thing on it
that we're all cheering our glass to so
what is that north star metric
and then she would say cool let's walk
around like you know who's at this party
and you know there's a little exercise
and as she unfolded this party it kind
of rev at first it got me in the mood
for winning right because it's like i'm
already working backwards from the
assumption that we've won
then i identify the north star goal and
then after we do that little game it
only takes two minutes then we would say
all right
uh so how are we going to get there
right what would be the things that we
would need to do now so that that party
happens
and all of a sudden we're we're talking
and brainstorming from a place of
certainty and confidence rather than
fear and doubt about not being able to
pull it off and the stress right because
when you're in fight fight-or-flight
your brain only works in a very limited
capacity compared to when you are you
know at ease relaxed which is why you
know great ideas come to you in the
shower because you're you're relaxed you
have warm water pouring on top of your
head and so your brain kind of melts
away and can start to you know put
together different data points that uh
that are not there when you're tense
and so i love this tactic of the holiday
party drawing game it really loosens
people up it gets them thinking it
focuses them on the north star goal and
then when you make a plan after that
they go into that plan from in a state
of mind of we already won
okay
now here's the opposite
this is called the um
the misery misery loves company tactic
okay so whenever we're making a plan at
the beginning of any plan everything
seems achievable
and um
everyone's optimistic
and it's hard to say it's one thing to
ask somebody what are the key risks in
this and then people you know again they
get a little defensive they use the
logical part of your brain so a better
question is
you know if i was to um let's say you
know we you go do this i go do my thing
and we get busy
and you know six months from now 12
months from now we we catch back up
we're getting a beer here at the local
pub
in the afternoon it's four in the
afternoon we go grab a beer and we say
man that idea was so cool
let's assume it went wrong right so man
that idea was so cool
i can't believe it didn't work out
now what happened
what is the what is the most likely
reason we would give
that things went south
and this is a way to identify the core
risk the chief assumption the riskiest
proposition
in your plan is to sort of work
backwards from we're getting a beer
we're hanging out it's already failed
and we say man that thing had so much
potential
what went wrong what do you think is the
number one reason it might go wrong and
then because you're identifying that up
front you can now like work against that
you can get you can game plan around
that
okay here's another one
i find that people get very defensive
about
the status quo especially the leaders
because as a leader you're sort of
responsible for the way that the company
works right you're responding like uh
you're responsible for how many people
work at your company right uh if i said
did you hire too many people most people
don't want to say yes and the reality is
that
certainly i don't know 20 30 40 of the
time the answer truly is yes you've
hired too many people
but if you ask ceos they'll rarely ever
say yes
and in the same way you'll say
are you working on a bunch of useless
stuff or are you working on a bunch of
extraneous things they would say no i
mean these are all important they're
valuable
right so people get defensive about
their current plan
and so how do you get how do you get
people to uh to identify
the fat in their their plan right be
able to trim the fat without the
pressure and the stress of them feeling
like they're wrong or they're being
blamed or that they're gonna have to
make some tough decisions have some hard
conversations and because of that they
just want to avoid it so here's what i
do
we play a game it's sort of like that
you know that f murder mary game right
where you decide you know if out of
these three choices who would you who
would you murder who would you marry who
would you have so um similarly let's
just focus on the murder part which is
like
if i asked you right so i could sit down
with with any manager in my company i
could say
in your team
if you i know you love your team and i
know they're they're all great they're
all great in their own ways but if you
had to do it
what would be the three who would be the
three people that you would cut if you
had to cut i'm not saying you will where
you're not going to cut anybody but who
would those three people be
similarly like out of all the projects
that initiatives are doing
what are the three that you would cut if
you had to cut three initiatives off
which ones would go
um you could do this with anything right
customers of all your customers on the
roster your clients who are the three
that you would cut where they're just a
pain in the ass it's not worth the juice
is not worth the squeeze and if you can
create a safe a safe space basically
where somebody can freely identify what
they would cut if they were gonna cut
but don't worry we're not asking you to
cut anything
uh and you do it yourself right you're
not just asking others to do this but
you do it yourself and you think aloud
maybe do it as a group like hey what
would we what projects would we cut you
know
which team members are really not you
know are at the bottom right there
certainly is a top at the bottom who is
that right which customers are the top
and the bottom
and if you can identify those it plants
a seed and people once they've said it
out loud they've heard a truth it's very
hard to unsee a truth and it might be a
month later or two months later or three
months later but eventually they will
decide to trim some of the fat either on
their team their projects or their
client list
that will help the team grow
so that's the f murder mary tactic okay
i think i've done
what is that uh four tactics okay let's
do another one
this is the superpower one so this is a
way to build people up so i did this at
my last startup
and people really resonated with this
which is i made a presentation
about each person in the team i did this
on a friday afternoon i said hey guys
let's go do a little happy hour and i
said i got a presentation for you guys i
said
you know i've learned that in any team
you can you can look for two types of
people you can look for people who
lack weaknesses meaning they're pretty
well-rounded they have no fatal flaws
but they may not be great at anything
right they're they're just good
they're at least good at everything
or you can have some people that are
amazing at some things and kind of weak
in other areas and i've learned that the
the best performing teams are filled
with people who are amazing in at least
one area so you're hiring for an extreme
strength not a lack of weakness right
that's an andreessen horowitz uh
framework that i really loved and so i
said i'd like to you know i said but the
funny thing is for most people they
don't they're not even aware
of what their extreme strength is
and um
because you're too close too it's so
normal for you to be great at it you
don't even really realize you're great
at it at some point it's other people
who point it out so i'd like to point
out for you the superpower that i've
seen each of you have and then i would
give and so i put each person's uh face
on a slide i would say hey this is like
for example hey this is derek derek's
our designer
derek what i've noticed is your
superpower i don't know if you're aware
of this but
most designers that i've worked with
they're creative types they're sort of
like you know messy desk procrastinator
types they pull all-nighters when they
get creative inspiration and they do
amazing work sometimes and other times
you know they get stuck with sort of a
creative writer's block of sorts
i said derek your superpower is that
you're a great designer
but you're like the mailman you deliver
every day at the same time right like i
give you the the brief i scribble a um a
scribble a poorly written address of
where where i'm trying to get this
package and you're able to interpret it
like a mailman and say oh i know where
this is trying to go and then you
deliver it every day at 5 00 pm before
you leave
and i said i you're like the mailman i
said and you know you don't work on the
weekends i know that you're not the type
of guy that i should be hitting up for
that like that crazy project we're gonna
do on the weekend so you're like the
mailman you deliver every day of the
week except for sundays and so i gave
them basically a superpower which is
you have this amazing ability to
consistently take a loose set of
instructions and deliver on it
and i gave him a nickname that goes with
it that's why i call you the mailman
and then yeah that's your superpower and
i gave it a little symbol and then i
like you know then went to the next
person i said oh this is fur con vercon
is
uh
you know he's not gonna win any awards
for for being the most eloquent speaker
or the the most politically um you know
polished kind of guy
but man when i when you talk to fur khan
it's almost like he's allergic to
[__] like you know when someone's
allergic to peanuts you can't even have
a peanut dish you feel uncomfortable
taking peanuts around them because you
might kill them i said that's what it's
like when i bring [__] around you i
don't even feel comfortable saying
[__] around you because you're so
good at seeing through [__] and
saying that doesn't make sense or
wait i thought you said this other thing
so how how could both of those be true
right and so i you know you were like um
you're allergic to [__] that is your
superpower you just can't stand it and
that because of that it makes the rest
of us up our game and not bring that
bring half-baked plans or incongruent
illogical plans to you because you'll
sniff it out in a second
and the beautiful thing is these things
are both true and aspirational meaning
they are this way but by giving it their
superpower they then want to live up to
that identity you've given them
and so you can kind of architect the
type of team you want by calling out
areas they're good but they not may not
be the best at it or they may not be
doing it all the time but by giving them
their superpower they will start to do
it more often okay so that's the
superpower technique
um
okay i'm gonna give you three quick ones
the tesla master plan if you've never
read it elon musk wrote a master plan
for tesla
um
you know back when it started so he
wrote the master plan v1 like 10 years
ago and then he wrote v2 and basically
he said
master plan v1 basically was like you
should go read it i've hand written his
many times and then wrote ours wrote my
own plan for my own business after
writing his
and so his plan basically says tesla's
job is to accelerate you know the um
the society's move off of fossil fuels
onto sustainable energy
to do that we need to create a car
that's high performance
and high efficiency
and so we're going to start with the
roadster the expensive car then we're
going to make
the next car then we're going to make
the the mass market model 3
car
blah blah blah and he's like you know so
in summary here's the master plan
build an expensive car to build the
brand build a less expensive car to get
more people on it then build the use the
economies of scale and the learnings
from production to build a mass-market
car that will get to everybody right
that's the master plan
um
and then he wrote a mastermind v2 but it
is very powerful if you can write the
master plan
for your company all right it's
basically any and it doesn't have to be
right right but it's you putting it out
there what are we here to do how do we
plan to do it and like you know here's
the takeaway and if you look at his
writing style it's very empowering style
and so
i like to take his master plan and then
write my own
all right the next one uh comes from the
ceo coach called matt makari or
something like that he has this
technique called the calendar audit
which is very simple imagine you print
out your calendar from the last week
and you
look at every
every meeting that was scheduled every
kind of block of time that you used and
you take three highlighters you take a
green highlighter that says
that was something that i enjoyed that
gave me energy you highlight those in
green then you take a red highlighter
you say these ones that i highlight in
red are the ones that i felt like my
soul was being sucked out of my body
right like these are the soul crushing
energy draining things that i dread
parts things of my day that i don't look
forward to you put those in red and then
you have the yellow that are like
neutral
and you look at that and then you say
okay this is an audit i now need to take
these red things and i need to figure
out over time how i'm going to get more
green than red right how i'm going to
phase all the red away and get to only
green
and
that might be hiring somebody who
doesn't who likes doing that thing
because what's red for you might be
green for them
or just getting rid of it or minimizing
the time you do it and saying do we
really need three meetings for this
could we not just do it in one could
this meeting be an email right or
whatever
so a calendar audit is a very valuable
technique okay so that was so so far
we've had number one the doctor house
screenshot technique number two my
wife's holiday party work backwards
question
number three the if we got a beer saying
you know saying man it's a bummer that
thing failed why did it fail right
that's number three number four is
creating a safe space for the f murder
mary game right who who are the three
that you would double down on who are
the three that you would cut
three is just a magic number it might be
three thousand for you i don't know
whatever it doesn't the number doesn't
matter same idea what are the bottom 20
of things what are the top 20 of things
is what you're trying to identify and
with the promise of we're not taking an
action on this right now
uh so that's
what four yeah that's four number five
was
tell each person their superpower and
give it to your team as a presentation
they will live up to that reputation
number six is the tesla master plan
number seven is the calendar audit okay
i'm gonna do two more maybe three um
number eight is peer groups so anytime i
have an objective like let's say i wanna
become uh you know a great poker player
or i want to get to 100 000 twitter
followers or i want to build a dvc brand
that does 50 million dollars a year
i will create a text chat group of five
other people who have were in the same
kind of ballpark as me of where they're
at now and have that same ambition as
their top ambition
uh mentors and advisors overrated peer
group underrated and so that's what i
would do and i would start by texting
them and then i would do like a once a
month kind of call where we could spend
three hours on the phone or in person
hanging out
shooting the [__] together sharing
tactics and strategies what's working
for them and trying to achieve your
mutually shared goal
okay last one is the kickoff document i
think this is number nine
a kickoff document is a template that i
have and i could share this but uh if
you subscribe to my newsletter i think
you get it so just go to seanpuri.com
and um
and i think you can get it uh or if not
just email me at sean shampoo.com okay
so the kickoff document is basically
something i do before i start a project
because i believe that clarity is power
and i think too often people go into
doing something without actually being
clear of what are we trying to do here
why are we trying to do it how will we
measure success and what's the first
thing that we should really do
and that's what a kickoff document does
so the kickoff dock has three sections
the first is what are we trying to do
it's one liner
the next is what's a win look like and i
define a win in two ways i say what's
the floor of this win meaning what is
the minimum that i would consider like a
successful good outcome like what's an
achievable thing
and then what's the f yeah win which is
the like the the result that would make
me safe f yeah then that really worked
and so now i get kind of like a range i
have like the bottom goal my floor goal
and then i have my my stretch goal
and um
and then i also do an anti-goal meaning
what are some traps that i could fall
into along the way
that would like make this whole thing
even if i hit my goals i would feel bad
at the end of it because i like did this
other thing right like for example we
all have these in life like uh
you know i would love to
um
be successful but i don't want to you
know screw over people along the way and
carry that guilt with me right so that's
a like
being successful financially would be
your goal i mean you'd put some numbers
around it but then your anti goal would
be
i don't want to do this in a way that
makes me feel unethical or ashamed in
any way of what i did i'd like to feel
proud of it right so those become your
anti-goals or like you know i'd like to
be successful but i want to be able to
make sure i'm home with my kids every
day at five because that's really
important to me so an anti-goal would be
yeah i made it happen but i'm never home
right so my anti goal would be you know
never getting home before you know next
time and so it's important to identify
your anti-goals they're very clarifying
for you
um
and the kickoff doc ends with one hour
or your power hour basically like what's
something i could do in the next hour
that would just get like create like
momentum uh get me to a win and so this
is not like do some research or make a
list it's like get momentum towards the
actual outcome so if i want to you know
increase sales that's like make a sale
make one sale or like if i wanted to
grow my list my email list it's like i
don't know post a thread on twitter in
the next hour that will get some
subscribers to my list just something to
get the ball rolling that's action
oriented so you're not just always in
planning mode
so those are nine different little tips
and tricks that uh really work for me
that i don't think you'll learn most of
those and i don't know business school
or you know at your job that peop you
know even if people try to do management
training it's usually not things like
this
uh these are my kind of like you know
unorthodox pet tricks that i like to do
that help me you know with my companies
and so i hope that's helpful for you if
it is let me know you can tweet it at me
at shaun vp if it's not helpful tweeted
me saying hey you know
wasn't that helpful honest feedback i
love honest feedback so either way works
for me
i'm at seanvp which is s-h-a-a-n-v-p
on twitter all right
[Music]
you